سنه 2022 المشرفه على نهايتها لم تحمل
معها بان صارتا للنازحين حول العالم فعدد
الفرين من اهوال الحروب والصراعات ارتفع
بشكل كبير على امتداد هذه السنه مسجلا
ارقام القياسيه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا تسببت في اسرع واكبر حركه
نزوح شهدها العالم منذ عقود فقد فقع عدد
اللاجئين الاوكران منذ بدايه عمليه
العسكريه والى غايه 20 من شهر ديسمبر
الجاري فاقه السته عشر مليون شخص وذلك
نقلا عن المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
حركه النزوح التي اعقبت الحرب الاوكرانيه
تتسبب في ارتفاع عدد سكان بعض الدول
المستقبله ابرزها المانيا الذي يتجاوز عدد
سكانها
84 مليون لاول مره في تاريخ الميلاد
اما في المتوسط فان وضع المهاجرين السريين
زاد سوءا حيث ذكر تقرير
في ايطاليا ان التقدير الادنى للاجئين
والمهاجرين الذين ماتوا او فقدوا في البحر
المتوسط من بدايه السنه والى غايه شهر
اكتوبر الماضي
1800 شخص بشكل عام سجلت اعداد اللاجئين
ارتفاع القياسيا حيث تجاوزت اول مره عتبه
المئه مليون ناجح حول العالم
[موسيقى]